walk him to this video playing grim
Mustang from XM pave punk right off ok
2601 and he's got two sixes and blitz as
well that's rather rather high and I
have played him two times with two
losses and he's not answering my t-phone
ok now he does let's see what is playing
yeah probably the moon fault yeah should
I try it again this vacuum line I do it
ok it's going for a sharp continuation
with the Ketchum mmm Wow how is this
plate I think I can take here OE 5mm mp5
I also wonder if there's maybe h5 like H
598 h 5 90 x b 5h 5 b-4 age 6 is also
very very weird try that cost me some
time it would be better if I actually
would know the line of course but it's
not like I'm studying this kind of stuff
all day i'm just experimenting here ok
e5 i can also go nite be fine after that
I e5 takes on c3 takes on f6 takes on
between wow yeah that's completely crazy
but I'm not much choice now ok I have to
take and now if I go Bishop c4 this may
be Bishop before check and I don't have
a good way to answer that mmm should I
am should I give the check on a four or
some other check the Queenie to know
what is this from a material point of
view actually I'm calm down while I'm
gone down we need for Quincy form hmm
not sure ok nothing much to do about it
this check is coming and I need to go to
have one it's probably not great for me
but it's also not one hundred percent
clear I believe this situation is still
very murky what to do them in very
interesting queen bee three the symbols
I put some pressure on f7 I'm not sure
now its success d 5 yes this is what I
expected actually I was thinking maybe
d5 opening up the long diagonal
35 is a weird move we are looking move
should our should I try knocking I must
I must play play some moves ok we can
take I don't mind that of course try
Luke age 42 f form try to oh well the
such a splendid okay that's not good if
I take on a six queen bee three a beam I
Scott Lucas six even so I cannot even
take on f6 okay can I take on f6 now
yeah I think I can push up here
fianchetto in the bishop
what a weird position ready yeah but now
i can take here now i can take this
before hanging maybe I could have done
that even instead of Bishop g7 and we're
time so that real time I'm a piece of
him for nothing actually that's cool
let's make sure that I actually win it
the game okay this night is a very sad
piece now
probably here now getting hmm getting
this morn into play yet the bishop on g7
is quite funny but it's not doing so
much it's just just sitting there not
helping my game too much I'm warning you
can go night t3 but I don't mind that I
take here this would also help my
coordination I want to get the bishop
back into play check that's a that's an
important thing to accomplish ok let's
see maybe just doing near see to you can
get something back with 94 bit it's a
don't mind its capture capturing here ok
and now maybe just regroup with this how
it will do that it's advancium 28
seconds well that's not good ready check
check
check
at least this is considerably easy to
play check check check check check check
check
check-check
yeah six seconds but I think that will
be enough check Brooke g3 and commenced
to MIT check checkmate Wow gamo and
sometimes just terribly slow and
realizing advantages yeah it was a bit
what slightly tricky because this bishop
on g7 is not doing something not doing
anything at the Fed first probably this
was just bad for idea this Queen d5 I
simply overlooked and the position is
probably not good anyway yeah i really i
don't know it i don't know this opening
its am probably wrong what I did h5 is
probably wrong yeah or just eat five so
what the computer is pointing out and
then taking on b5 yeah well this looks
looks much easier at least yeah I'm not
quite sure where is even going I mean in
a position like that see Freud's maybe
just going to fall and h4 while looking
somewhat silly I mean there is age 5 so
some some short cancels is not so easy
to do yeah but this is this is probably
probably oh oh I'm just very very stupid
I can play Queen a phone Wow and I'm
winning just check I'm just winning here
because I'll get the pawn oh that's what
that was a very stupid mistake not to do
that I mean the problem is what is he
doing let's say is playing 97 for
example I take here I'll get see form
and then I'm a pawn up and I have this
pawn on age 6 which completely kills his
castling and everything terrible
position yeah this is flat-out winning
so before us was it was really a bad
move then maybe h5 it's not that
terrible
but this this is of course complete
nonsense in comparison here black is
just having the data game he's a pawn up
and I don't really have any compensation
for it I mean this was the icing on the
cake that i blundered that ok for here
yeah well f6 is hanging this is why
Bishop a6 wasn't really doing much good
but here he must probably do something
else rugby aid for example rook bada so
that be4 is protected now Bishop a six
now look before as covered maybe yeah
but I can I can of course continue this
game it's not like I'm loss or so rookie
idea one loss or something like that
just a very complicated position that's
not really yeah and what he did I mean
this is just blundering a PCM basically
and that's it yeah I played it probably
probably wrong I mean yeah here it's
probably just a root a 7s rugby 7s bet I
am yeah yeah that's just this is much
better I thought that this and then I
needed to go back because of the pawn
but that's just just wrong I can stay on
the 7th of course and you can quickly
see that this is entirely unplayable as
I'll get naija five with the meeting
attack I mean the a porn is not relevant
ok this would have been much much
quicker and here well I think I'm i was
i was really winning in this end game
all the time yeah it just took a while
to DN k if he would have gone back i
think i would have maybe sacrifice on c5
just to make it easier to play with them
okay
it's not the best move i can i have
actually this one which is quite strong
okay check a 20m and now to check check
yeah well here it is here this is
getting rather simple even with 20
seconds on the clock so yeah very good
sculpt here win against against this jug
of the Sun GM alright thanks for
watching